l'école pour certains ce sont de mauvais
souvenirs pour d'autres de bons
souvenirs mais on a tous des souvenirs
de nos moments passés en classe ou en
cours de récréation il certaine
nostalgie que vous pouvez revivre à
voisins le bretonneux depuis le 30
novembre on en parle avec vous mélanie
poké bonsoir comment ça c'est votre
rendez-vous loisirs ouais c'est même un
vrai moment de madeleine de proust même
les plus jeunes peuvent être touchés par
cette exposition les grands parents les
parents peuvent ainsi faire découvrir
comment c'était pour eux à l'école on
retrouve les plumes les buvards les
fameuses leçons de morale aussi les
blues alors mais l'école actuelle est
aussi bien représenté puisque on peut
découvrir l'été ni les fameux tableau
numérique interactif où le robot nao
leur l'exposition a été pensé par le
club des collectionneurs des yvelines
avec la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
un mot du président tous les objets qui
sont dans cette classe sont d'époque
seuls les tables pédagogiques ont été
reconstitués afin effectivement de
permettre à l'ensemble des visiteurs et
des étudiants ou écoliers de comprendre
l'évolution de l'école
nous voulions montrer ce qu'était une
école en 1900 et surtout montré
également comment évoluent évoluer
l'école depuis les années à venir depuis
la création de l'école jusqu'aux années
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de numérique alors l'exposition
est à découvrir jusqu'au 18 décembre à
la maison de covile allégorie c'est une
très jolie plongée dans l'histoire
écolières et on peut même se tester à
l'écriture avec la plume et ça vaut le
coup merci mélanie pour cette idée de
sortie dans un instant on vous retrouve
à la présentation du 7-8 loisirs avec
d'autres idées de sorties à faire ce
week-end